it is a gorgeous sunrise that sun's been
slipping in and out of the clouds that
are around
these clouds will start to thin out
we'll start to pick up some
drier southwest breezes as we get into
the afternoon hours and then the
high pressure will kind of shift to push
the monsoon away from us
for a few days and we'll dry a little
bit more i don't think we'll completely
dry out but we'll definitely have a
drier influence and that'll feel a lot
better
80 degrees right now look at the dew
points in the mid 60s
telling us there's still a lot of juice
in the atmosphere near 60
humidity so the sun on its way up and
sunrise at 7 58.
a lot of 70s around this morning we've
had some nice cooling even with the
cloud cover overnight
still in the low 80s green valley to the
strip to downtown low 70s out there
at red rock this morning 77 indian
springs 79 in boulder city 86 in
laughlin
just under 100 degrees at death valley
mesquite picked up some nice rain again
callaghany and a lot of lincoln county
got pounded by some heavy
rain and big thunderstorms and kingman
boy
with rainfall totals over an inch
between midnight and 3 a.m
pounded with big thunderstorms and so
much lightning beaver dam up around
littlefield that's just north of
mesquite
before st george before southwest utah
up there almost half an inch mesquite
picked up another over a tenth of an
inch of rain and rhodes ranch in the
southwest valley
did manage to pick up less than a tenth
of an inch of rain so we did pick up
some
in the valley high pressure again will
start to cap off the monsoon
and we'll get a southwesterly flow here
starting today
into friday and saturday so again that
will dry us out a little bit
still looking for thunderstorms possible
today up in lincoln county
over into mohave county northwest
arizona but look at that line of
thunderstorms
it just traveled right down u.s 93
through dolan springs they picked up
half an inch of rain but
kingman just getting clobbered and you
can see the
few cells that did pop up around the
valley and to the south
especially over south valley
neighborhoods and then south of boulder
city got some
big lightning down there over the
mccullough range all right so we're
looking at 108
for our thursday afternoon high we'll
start to see some feel some drying and
the clouds thinning out good sunshine
a little drier still and still breezy
friday temperatures come
down a little bit but the monsoon slips
back in
on sunday and we'll look for a slight
chances for thunderstorms i like that
103
103 on monday 106. so it looks like
temperatures will be up and down a
little bit into next week